[Music]
well one interesting thing about the
algorithms that predict future behavior
and psychological traits or intimate
traits of people is that you know people
often think oh my god this is science
fiction you know like how could that be
or they say oh my god this is totally
impossible
now it's in fact pretty intuitive look
if you know someone pretty well you will
be able to predict their future behavior
you even if you don't know exactly
whether you know they read a given book
or not you're reading this book now and
you think oh my god you know the friend
of mine you know the one that is you
know so well organized and always talks
about you know this given thing he or
she would really love this book what you
made here you made a prediction right
you know your friend you know their
psychological traits you notice some of
their intimate traits and it allows you
to extrapolate from the knowledge you
have about the friend into new areas you
basically see a new book or see a new
play or hear about a new activity and
you can predict which one of your
friends would like it now computers
basically computer algorithms do exactly
the same thing they would take a set of
behaviors that a given person has
expressed in the past now match it with
behavior of many other people that the
algorithm has in its database and then
say hey you know people who read these
books or people who listen to this type
of music or people who visit these
websites they also tend to vote
conservative or you know study
psychology or work as accountants so now
we can basically just make those very
simple predictions when I said simple
but then on a large scale they basically
become very powerful
a lot of signal that is useful for an
algorithm would not be useful for a
human being let me give you an example
if I tell you the politicians that you
know I like you would have no trouble
figuring out what my political views are
perhaps even if I gave you know ten of
my favorite books it will be still
informative to you as a human being you
know okay so people who read those books
you know they tend to have this
political leaning or this religious
leaning and so on but now if I told you
look those are you know the ten you know
games I played recently or this is the
brand of the shoes that I'm wearing now
as a human being you'll be like yeah
like it's probably not very revealing
about your political views or
religiosity simply because it's kind of
difficult for us to match a brand of the
shoe or game with particular ideology or
worldview now the fact that it's
difficult for us to see the link it
doesn't mean that the link it doesn't
exist right the link could be there it
just could be subtle enough to fall
below our threshold of perception now a
computer has a big advantage here it can
store and process way more data that
then humans can in terms of links in the
relationships like that so it might be
that when you look at a huge database of
millions of other people it might be
that people who wear a given brand of
shoes they have a slight liberal or
conservative leaning something that
would be imperceptible for humans for a
computer it's a useful bit of
information a useful bit of information
that is not conclusive but now if you
add up thousands or millions of little
crumbs of inconclusive information like
that you can in fact arrive at the very
accurate profile
[Music]
to answer this question we collected a
lot of digital footprints and we used
Facebook as our research environment we
asked people to share with us their
Facebook Likes and Facebook status
updates and then we also asked the same
participants to feel in questioners
personality questioners iq question as
happiness questionnaires and so on and
then we build machine learning models
that would predict the scores of these
people on this question as from the
digital footprints and once we've done
that we would take a group of new
participants that the algorithm has
never seen before and we try to predict
their scores on self-reported
questionnaires which we use to measure
the accuracy of the algorithmic approach
to measuring in psychological traits and
it turns out that those methods are very
highly accurate to give you an example
we compare the accuracy of these
algorithms of the algorithms based on
Facebook Likes with the accuracy of
human judges you would give questioners
personality questionnaire in this case
to friends and family members of our
participants and would ask them to fill
in those questionnaires in the name of
the participant right so basically based
on their acquaintance with the
participant they were supposed to answer
the questionnaire in their names in
their name so then what you would get
you would get basically personality
scores of the participants as predicted
by their friends and family members and
then on the other hand we had their
scores as predicted by the computer
algorithm based on your Facebook Likes
and now we could compare how many men
how many likes do you need to be as
accurate as a given friend or family
member and what we found is that you
need only 10 likes you need to give
algorithm only 10 likes for the
algorithm to be as accurate as your work
colleague you need around 100 likes for
the algorithm to be as accurate when
predicting your personality
as your family member like brother or
mother would be and finally you need
around 200 likes to beat the most
accurate of human judges your own spouse
[Music]
so in the past if I wanted to know your
political views either I needed to
basically become close with you and you
know have you shared those views with me
though we know that even close friends
very often do not discuss certain ideas
and do not share all of the information
all of their intimate traits with each
other now I could also give you a
questionnaire in the past and ask you
hey can you please fill this
questionnaire and you had full control
over hey whether you are actually going
to respond to this question or not and
if you decided to respond to a
questionnaire you still had a choice of
not answering their questions honestly
which basically means that you had full
control one can say or or a large degree
of control over your intimate traits
that you did not want to share with the
others now if I can make the same
predictions if I can predict your
intimate traits such as your political
views sexual orientation religious et
personality intelligence or whether your
parents were divorced or not if I can
predict all of those things by simply
providing an algorithm with the list of
songs that you have listened to or the
list of websites that you have visited
in recent hours or days this basically
means that we are heading towards the
post privacy era your time where people
will not have rights to privacy
[Music]
when I started studying these algorithms
I was mostly focus on the downside I
thought it was very scary that you can
have a computer algorithm that takes
seemingly innocent and seemingly an
informative piece of data such as your
playlist on Spotify or bunch of Facebook
Likes and can extrapolate from this data
to make very accurate predictions about
your intimate traits such as your
political views religiosity sexual
orientation personality IQ and so on
this was pretty scary for me I did not
expect I did not expect the algorithms
to be as accurate I thought well there
was some accuracy but we could quickly
learned that the accuracy of the
algorithms is higher than what people
could achieve and it's also higher than
what could be done with questioners
especially in terms of trades that
people are not really happy to share
with the others like you know you don't
really share your political views or
your sexual orientation with people that
you don't know really well and I think
it only came later it appeared later to
me that you know there are risks there
but are also tremendous opportunities
let's say to make the world a safer and
more fair place as in you know matching
people with better jobs or let's say
monitoring the psychological health and
extending those benefits to people who
are traditionally deprived of it
[Music]
well I think that people are really
willing to share the data and give up
the data simply because it's really
beneficial to us right think about
Google Maps it's an amazing tool that
helps us to get from point A to point B
in a shortest possible time and while
burning least fuel it's amazing both on
the personal level but also on the
society level we we saving a lot of
hours and a lot of gallons of fuel which
is also great for environment and so on
now for Google Maps to work what
basically need to happen is that you can
use it to find your way to work but you
can also you have to share the
information about how you were driving
around with the platform because then
the platform can use this data that it
collects it from you to optimize the
routes for other people right so I think
there's no going back from from here
people get so much in return for sharing
the data that it's unlikely that will be
now willing to give up Google Google
Maps Facebook Amazon Kindle Netflix and
all of the other platforms that
basically make make our lives easier
safer more interesting fulfilling and so
on well I think we certainly need good
legislation and good technology to help
us to maintain as much privacy as
possible but I think that in the long
term the game here is lost we the sooner
we accept that we are heading towards
the future without privacy the sooner we
can focus on trying to organize the
societies and organize the policies
technology and even cultures in such a
way as to accommodate the world without
privacy to large extent it is an
uncharted territory what in the past
required huge institutions spying on
people trying to predict their intimate
rates keeping tabs on them requires
enormous amount of effort money and
men power today the same thing can be
achieved you know by a guy in a dorm
room with a laptop and internet
connection and you know a few hundred
dollars to spend on you know databases
that can be purchased on official or
unofficial data markets which basically
completely changes the game and I think
that the sooner that people accept the
fact that basically there is no privacy
going forward
the safer and the society will become
the sooner you realize that whatever you
write in an email
can be read by motivated others the
sooner that we all realize that being an
ASIS or being gay or being liberal
conservative is something that basically
people will know about well they could
probably very easily infer it now and
definitely we just get easier in the
future
the sooner we can focus on making
societies more tolerant and open-minded
educating the voters to to make them
more difficult to manipulate and
basically organizing the societies and
preparing them for post previous era
[Music]